[Music]
I'll just give a quick talk about the
extensions that we added in order to
support 3d graphics output in Ex windows
and support for non core devices used
for 3d interaction reading reiterating a
bit about what bronco mentioned one of
the key features of the system is the
high performance 2d graphics hardware
that we want to take advantage of and
having host processes access to shared
structure memory directly we had
considered implementing a full 3d wire
protocol but there are a number of
things that precluded that one being the
ex extension mechanism was still
evolving X itself was still evolving we
wanted to get it done and we didn't
necessarily want to take the performance
hit of having to create graphic
structures over the X wire so the
current implementation has 3d graphics
clients building structures directly
instruction memory and requesting
traversal without having to go over the
X wire we've added a minimum 3d
extension 3d in quotes here to provide
windowing support for the 3d and address
some synchronization issues and a
separate input extension to support the
additional devices ok real quick here in
core X we've defined there's to find a
bitmap graphics function which under
control the graphics context takes
bitmap primitives and renders them into
drawables and the 3d sides that it's a
little more a little more complicated
here you want to take 3d primitives
build nodes out of them put them into
structures then traverse the structures
once they're complete passing the 3d
data into
geometry process which will do two 3d
transformations clipping and then in the
case of polygons do some rendering as
lighting calculation shading
calculations and then put it in the next
draw these contexts here you could look
at as in aggregate as being a 3d
graphics context but as we'll see they
map in two different places on our
system we also had to add some
additional attributes to extra O's in
order to provide support for double
buffering and z-buffering that the 3d
graphics wanted to take advantage of
let's just take a quick look at how add
a little a little too much copy on this
slide here I think of how those
functions map into our system because we
have the 3d bypass mechanism the
formatting and the structure building
take place in the 3d client and that
builds the client data structure
directly in structural memory here and
then at some point the traversal context
the crystal process is executed by the
structure walker in the graphics
subsystem passes his data on through the
geometry pipe and into the renderer here
these contexts are modified on the fly
by the process here which is a bit
different than the way X binds the
attributes right when you wish for the
primitives on the server side we added
some additional attributes to the to the
window and in order to set up the
graphics subsystem in order to put the
the data in the right place in the right
format we had to build some structure in
order to set that up and the thing that
binds it all together is this traversal
context which will call upon the display
context to set up the 3d destination and
then call the client structure in order
to render the image and a lot like the
core graphics context the Trostle
context values are cached in the client
process which
allows the 3d client to directly request
traversals so there isn't much going
over the wire here okay just this just
shows how the traversal context works to
tie things together we're in this case
you can have two traversal contacts
which are pointing to two different
structures and they render 3d graphics
into the same window and here two
traversal contacts would access
different parts of the same structure
where once you Russell contacts would
perform draught reversals and another
one might perform a hit test traversal
on the same structure or right back in
order to do some plotting whatever and
here are the attributes that are found
in the traversal context that basically
specify how and when traversals are
going to occur and where the destination
is and where the source is moving right
along there's some issues that are
raised when trying to do bitmap 3d
graphics into bitmap windows one is how
do you map the 3d images into an x
window where where typically 3d graphics
are wound up being mapped into some
canonical volume here in our case from
minus 1 1 plus 1 1 and which is square
an x window bitmap graphics are defined
as far as pixel locations in a window
which may not necessarily be square so
you have questions that's how do you map
that data another issue was support for
the double buffering and z-buffering
which we saw by adding a additional
attribute we found that we had to
synchronize in some cases 3d traversal
with bitmapped operations as far as
windowing manipulations you don't want
to be rendering a 3d image as you're
moving windows around the screen because
the the structural Walker is a
asynchronous process and also there's
the idea of using the graphic structure
as a backing store for the 3d window
where if you move your window you can
cause a redisplay traversal to occur and
your image is back
we asked us all the question where they
wanted to mix 3d and bitmap windows
bitmap graphics in the same window and
there was it wasn't clear how would you
do that since the 3d graphics for in
structure mode and ax bitmap graphics
are in immediate mode and you'd have to
play games with building bitmap nodes in
3d structures so we we we punted on that
issue for the for the time and then we
had to handle some events generated by
the graphics subsystem that occur at
traversal time just a quick picture here
of what I was talking about as far as
the problem of map and 3d graphics into
a window if you happen to have a some
rectangular window that you have to put
3d graphics and you ask yourself the
question do I want to maintain this
aspect ratio of the object and also
where do I place the object in the
window so this this base geometry
extender attribute works in tandem with
the window bit gravity and as I'll show
here the easy way is just to map the the
viewport boundaries with the the window
boundaries and you distort the object
the other options here are to maintain
the aspect ratio of the object here you
try to keep this square window within
your X window and using the big gravity
you can place it wherever you want um
here is is a congress of that where you
you want to map it's the major axis here
minus one to one and you scale the other
axis so you lose some data and another
option is to maintain the size of the
object and resizing just shows more or
less if your object and a few notes
about the input extension we had to
support such advices as knobs tablets
button boxes things you normally see in
a 3d workstation and features here is we
wanted to allow you to obtain device
data via either an event delivery or
poling explosively for the data we
wanted to support some time sensitivity
filters in case of dial so you can
easily overload the server by reporting
to many events there and we wanted to
control the alphanumeric labels or LEDs
on the devices since the X was still in
a bit forming up we decided to first
tackle a a simple mechanism but focusing
device input to a client and in fact we
do currently focus device into a
particular client and not a window as
you normally see in acts and it's it's
rude and the fact that one client
focusing a device will take it away from
other client this also has to work with
standard window managers so we didn't
have support for focusing devices say in
a banner you click a little button to
get focus for the tablet we didn't want
to deal with that
so here the client himself different
Ehrman's went to focus using focus in or
event enter notify events so it's pretty
pretty thin there ok one second and the
last slide as far as the what we
consider in the future to do with the
input extension used to have a more
sophisticated focusing strategy where
they look more like core four devices
and we focus of ice through window
looking at input context where we
wouldn't have to reload device state
upon focusing and adding some local
device interaction as for example
connecting a dial directly to to a
matrix and the possibility of
downloading some interaction routines in
order to do that local processing and a
server and last but not least looking
into some asynchronous event delivery
that some people seem to
like over the current pulmo a lot of
people contributed to this project and
it was their efforts that enabled it to
to work after after all of this and it's
not only the people that were directly
on the project with a lot of other
people that worked on various components
of the system
[Applause]
ten seconds of I'm sorry
okay
but
good morning I'm Phil gust
I'm from Hewlett Packard Laboratories
and I'm gonna be discussing a topic that
I call X in a distributed multi-user
environment what does that mean well
we've got this idea of the distributed
computing environment and the idea of
DCE is that you've got a person and you
have resources scattered all over the
place and the focus is to get that
person access to distributed resources
that's the current DCE model what we
think is that the future of DCE isn't
going to be so much on the access to
remote resources as it is to access to
remote people that is to say the support
of groups working together I think night
the 1980s are going to see this as the
major thing for computing well we got
together and thought about what the
implications were for most of the
systems on the workstations and one of
the things we thought about was what is
the implication for the user interface
of a distributed computing environment
that supports groups of people working
together and one of the things the most
rudimentary things that we can do is to
support the idea of sharing Windows that
are already in existence among a group
of workstations so that people can work
at them as though they were sitting in
front of the same terminal so we've come
up with a concept of shared Windows in a
multi user interface and schematically
it means that there's a lot of other
ways you can accomplish the same thing
through somatic layers and remote
procedure calls and all that but I think
that there's some use for allowing the
interface to participate in that what
would you do is such a thing if you had
it well there's a number of things you
could do from very low level to fairly
high level at the fairly low level you
could share an individual window that
represented an application with someone
else for instance you could have
a debugger running and push it at
somebody else and say I've got a problem
can you look at it and you can both work
on it another thing you could do would
be to share entire window hierarchies
such as your root window so that you
could do consulting I've got a problem
would you look at this group of
applications and find out why it's
misbehaving and the third thing that you
can do is to create specific workspaces
graphic workspaces for particular
purposes such as a chemical analysis if
you have a suite of chemical analysis
applications and to put all your
chemical analysis workbench running
there and sort of switch channels or go
into that place in order to work
together on a particular problem so
here's my mom and apple pie slide but
the goals are sort of can we have it all
what we'd like to do is to allow
existing acts applications to continue
to work in this environment and maybe be
improved to the extent that a lot of X
applications become immediately
group-oriented applications because the
window system supports that with some
caveats that you have to be careful how
you use certain things if I type an A
and you type of being an Emacs buffer
for instance is that okay well if it is
then we're for you and also we'd like to
provide additional capabilities so that
new applications can be written in order
to exploit the sharing specifically can
we write group oriented applications
using this kind of thing
well there's some extensions that I
think are necessary to any windowing
system model or any interface model and
I'll address myself to X specifically
you need the concept of what does it
mean to be a view of a particular window
on a particular display as opposed to
the window itself right now a window and
a view are synonymous because there's
one and only one but if I had one window
and five of us were looking at it on
five different displays on workstations
then you need the logical concept of a
view and multiple views of a particular
window in order to make this work you
need operations that manipulate create
and destroy views such as sharing a view
to create multiple multiple views how
can I share them what are the rules for
that kind of thing what are the
operations there's some interesting
problems dealing with sub windows when
you create views what are the rules for
sub windows of views that are shared for
example what are the rules for inputs
and sub views that are shared what's the
behavior of input in general again if I
type a you type B that's fine what if
we're drawing and both of us put the pen
down at the same time and start code
wrong on something and finally what does
it mean to point at something the
current implementation of X supports a
local pointer but if I want to say no no
this up over here tap-tap that's a
little bit harder you reduced to some
pretty rudimentary verbal descriptions
over the telephone to make that work
to get out some of these what what we've
done is to implement a little toy
library under x10 and the reason we did
that was simply because we had x10 we
didn't have x11 in any form that that
was reasonable to use so we said can we
make some progress here the library is
not the right way to do it but it helped
us understand what the right thing to do
was and it didn't wasn't too painful to
do or throw away we made some
assumptions in order to make this work
well fixed color maps fixed fonts fixed
tiles I didn't want to get at that I was
trying to get at some of the much more
simple underlying issues and I'll worry
about the really hairy stuff later
specifically when I get text 11 we did
some fairly sleazy things like
on-the-fly broadcast of pix maps when
they were needed so if I created a new
window I copy off the old window on
somebody else's server and update yours
for example that's probably the wrong
way to do it and performance issues show
us that that's true that's the wrong way
to do it but there are some right ways
let me show you what the internal
structure this library looked like it's
not too important but it sort of helps
you understand what we're doing we
created a set of Records for each of
these concepts of a few display and
window and we shadowed a lot of the
resources so for instance when I opened
a display I create a display record yet
insert the actual display stuff in it
plus some other things that I need to
make all this shared stuff work the same
thing with Windows we put the real
window idea in the window record and
then give you this fake window ID that
looked just like a window ID in fact it
was called window so applicant the goal
was could an application that was
already there be linked into this new
library and still work hopefully the
answer is no we didn't learn anything
and then we had view records which were
actually instances of Windows on
particular displays and what we did is
we created local windows put them in the
view records and then managed those
there's sort of two things that you have
to do to discover what needs to be done
in a window system like this one is what
about reinterpreting existing X commands
so that things more or less work out if
if you've done it right perhaps a lot of
applications will work just because
you've placed the correct interpretation
on the existing excrements some of the
things that you'd have to reinterpret
obviously are rendering algorithms
because you need to multi multi render
on various displays opening and closing
displays some things like creating
destroying windows input processing
turned out to be a real challenge
because you really like to be able to
distinguish where the input was coming
from if I type and you type some
applications by care and some
applications don't care and the ones
that don't care should see things just
as they are where the input streams are
just coalesced at the at the at the
application level
and finally resource management there's
a whole bunch of new commands that you
might want to add in order to exploit
the sharing of to write shareable
applications and I'll show you an
existing application that has to know
about sharing in a minute we need some
ability to create new views and I call
that operation sharing and to destroy a
particular view I call that uncaring you
might want to be able to specify what
the parent of a new window view is when
you share it we need some way of
querying for a list of active views on a
particular window and we have a call
like that that allocates up some space
and returns a list of these things that
I call view info structures they're
useful in a couple other places they
carry some exhilarate information that
there wasn't room for in the normal X
input structure so rather than go trying
to extend that right now we simply
created an exhilarating structure that
you can do a query to and finally being
able to query for some more information
from the last event that you got for
instance
which of you did this this a come from
so I can do the correct thing with it if
another user was already typing along I
might just save it up for instance until
that user was done typing
what I want to show you is a videotape
that we did of a toy application it's a
it's a whiteboard program along the
lines of one that Xerox PARC has had
running for a little bit in their collab
and the main point wasn't beauty or
anything else like that in fact we had a
graphic designer
we had a graphic designer designed some
very nice icons for that I didn't get
time to knit into this the the point was
to get at some of thorny problems and
this particular application is
specifically knowledgeable about sharing
I don't know whether this is gonna work
out so I can't commit to it being a
product or anything else like that
this is a sort of schematic picture of
this shared whiteboard so you can sort
of see what it's about it has a central
area which is a draw window I've been a
tool trade down at the bottom and an
easel up at the top the scenario is that
I have a whiteboard I'm working on some
difficult problem and I call a
collaborator to ask her to look at this
problem - what I'm gonna do is to push a
copy of my whiteboard at her and I'm
going to sort of describe what the
problem is by doing some drawing I'll so
I'll select the colour then I'm going to
draw from out of the tool tray and I
will draw this region and you can see it
being drawn on the other side as well
what we've done is we've done some
transaction handling so that a thousand
transactions or something like that
happened before they flushed out to the
other views we can control that
completely what she's gonna do is sort
of indicate which region she thinks is
appropriate and then suggest an
alternative here's where a pointer would
have been nice because we could have
just said no this one and instead what
she's doing is sort of drawing through
this one and she's gonna indicate oh you
might shape that region now what I'm
gonna ask asked high-wind to do in this
tape is I've got to go do something else
she's the expert could could she please
continue looking at the problem she
agrees so her view stays up and I'm
going to shut my view down and go do
something else so this is an idea of not
only can we share but we can also have
the idea of giving to somebody else I
can give you the monkey which is a very
useful
hmm-what from a management point of view
is a very intelligent thing to do so
there's there's a living breathing
example of an application which does
this some of the Nattie problems we run
it ran into I'll point out in a little
bit this is a schematic picture of that
application there's a tool tray down
here which has drawing and erasing and
typing tools there's a neat little tray
up here where you can tear off what's in
the central screen and put it up so you
can have five or six of these drawings
pending all at once and there's a
central drawing area for the current
drawing now to use color coding here to
indicate that the red windows are shared
that's to say the application
specifically when it creates a new
instance of a whiteboard links in these
shared windows and the blue windows are
non shared and you'll notice my root
window for the application is not shared
and the tool tray everybody has their
own tool trace so that I can draw in red
and you can erase all at the same time
and finally the easels we don't like to
see what we've all torn off and put up
there and off to the right there I've
drawn a tree which kind of shows you how
that structure looks some of them are
unique windows in a particular
workstation some of them are shared
among the application what I'd like to
do is to show you some of the
implications of being able to share
windows and to create these kind of
linkages I'm going to show you a
sequence of slides and each of these
represents some some action on the
previous slide we have two servers DX
and dy with some window hierarchies on
each and the first operation that I'm
going to do is to share with Addie why a
particular sub window structure from DX
so there I've done it I've shared X two
and one of the things is this WYSIWYG
concept what what you see is there what
you see is what I see of concept was he
whiz whiz he whiz concept says that the
sub windows have to go with it okay
and there's some particular geometric
implications of that about positions
within sub-windows but those windows are
actually running on the blue server and
they're a view of them is on the red
server the color indicates if which
server died with those windows go away
the next thing that I'm going to do is
on the on the red server dy I'm going to
create a window and all of a sudden it
magically appears on the on the DX
server as well because after all it's a
sub window of a shared window and so the
rules are it shows up there - and
everywhere else the next thing that I'm
going to do is kind of kinky I'm going
to take two existing windows y2 from
from dy and X 3 from DX and I'm going to
make those sub windows of that new y 6
that says that I can have multiple views
even on the same server pending under
that so this is a really horrible
situation but if you implement it
correctly this is possible in fact it's
even desirable the times
there's some real serious problems to
doing this and what we want to get at is
what does it imply in terms of windows
system design to hit these problems and
to think about these in advance the
claim is that I believe it's possible to
modify the X Window System to make this
work it's probably possible to modify
the news Windows system to make this
work in any future window systems but
the point I want to make about all this
is that it's important to think about it
in advance like any other piece of good
design you have to know what the problem
you're attacking is there's there's some
real bad problems needing to share other
resources used with Windows for instance
pixmap graphics context whatever else
and part of the approach is for instance
the per color window Maps per window
color maps are a good start but you need
a lot of other things linked to
individual views that go along with it
when it's shared we could do some things
like larger resources could be demand
loaded on render time or whatever else
these are classical operating system
problems of when you bring resources in
page resources in and you could cache
for efficiency there's a new networking
concept that's going to be implemented
relatively soon in commercial systems
and it's called multi casting and the
idea is I can send one message out to a
mailing list of servers for example and
they all get the same thing that's very
convenient in terms of implementing the
shared Window System because I don't
want to have to have in broadcast events
to get out to end servers I'd like to
broadcast one thing and it gets out to
all of them very efficient but there's
some problems with the way things are
done right now that make that difficult
and part of it is can we correct that
we'd like to be able to send a pixmap
out and have it mean the same thing to
all possible servers you'd like to send
a bunch of stuff out and have mean the
same thing to all possible servers and
what we'd like to do is to have each
server sort of resolve it in terms of
its server specific stuff when it gets
there rather than trying to send server
specific ones out for each one so you
might want to for instance send
translation Maps when things
two particular servers and that's okay
sometimes but the bulk of your
transmission should be server
independent
inputs multiple views are a real problem
in the drawing program for instance I
had to be specifically knowledgeable
about drawing because if I put my pen
down and you put your pen down we both
start code wrong at the same time or Co
erasing which we do sometimes in
whiteboards you'd like to be able to
keep those separate if you care and we
had to write the application so that we
were specifically knowledgeable about
which view was giving us the input by
the axillary query what you might want
to do instead is to adopt a more
transaction based model so that you
could keep extended transactions like
drawing distinct or any other extended
transactions you like you'd like to
allow applications or for instance the
user interface management system to be
able to define what a transaction was
for a particular group of windows or a
particular application and finally you'd
like to be able to define appropriate
default transactions so that
applications not written to take
advantage of sharing could nonetheless
coexist with applications that work
finally a social type of thing I would I
would be really loath to think somebody
could wander into my window system and
steal a window users are very
uncomfortable with that concept so what
I would like to do is to address privacy
problems and again the solution the
first first step in solving that problem
is to think about in advance you don't
want to implement a particular social
policy in a Window System my claim is
but you'd like to provide adequate tools
so that users who care can and they can
have different ones some of the issues
for instance are to give individual
control over who can share my resources
X sort of does that right now in terms
of who can put something on my screen
more than that I'd like to allow control
over how things that I have shared get
used this capability idea so for
instance if I give you a window can you
pass it on to a third person or does it
stop there the least I might be able to
do is have read and write bits so that
you could look at a window for instance
but not modify the window I could say
look at this but I might want to go
further than that in terms of what I can
do with this window once I've got a view
of it once I've been given a view of it
and finally the bottom line control of a
window might want to stay with the with
the server that with the application
that created it on the machine where
it's actually executing again if which
machine dies does the entire all views
of that window go away so there's the
bottom line control I can turn off my
machine or kill that window
and finally what are some future
directions for this kind of work well
I'll look into my crystal ball and I'll
say that we need to assess the impact on
application architecture there's a lot
of things that you may have to change in
your application architecture just as
there were a lot of things that had to
change when people started adopting
toolkits that modified or inverted the
program architecture you might suspect
that there's some things that have to be
done in applications in order to exploit
sharing properly you'd also like to
consider window management implications
of this stuff what does it mean for
instance to have two window managers
controlling views on particular servers
which is the way they would do now and
yet those window management policies
perhaps being in conflict because
they're shared and if a window moves on
one screen it also moves on the other if
it's a sub window of a shared window
you'd like to be able to understand what
to do in that case there's also some
neat things you might be able to do you
might be able to create a group
environment type window manager that
supports the rooms like concept for
example out of this you could already
sort of do that under x11 anyway but it
would be even more fun if we had a group
oriented one running across machines
where there wasn't a monolithic process
controlling that but instead a bunch of
cooperating rooms like window managers
that can make this work and each of us
has different views of rooms perhaps if
I want to we you could see that in the
slide if I if I took something from my
room and moved it to a shared area we
parented it to be a sub window of a
shared window that's kind of like moving
into a public room and similarly if I
took something out of a shared area and
moved it as a sub window of a private
window that's sort of like putting into
a private room so there's a start there
at a concept of being able to do that
there's also social problems with being
able to do that - for instance taking
something from you finally I'd like to
look at what higher level user interface
toolkits you would need and how you
would exploit this concept in existing
toolkits for instance if I bring up a
menu and I don't know which one to
choose could I push the copy of the menu
at you and say here I don't know which
one to pick what do you think and
perhaps you can pick it instead
I mean that's a perfectly plausible
thing to do that we do in real life but
we'd like to be able to do on our
electronic real life stew which is
sometimes more real than stressing me
more real so that's sort of what I've
been thinking and if anybody has some
thoughts about some things that I've
left out or some help they could give me
in terms of suggesting directions I'd be
glad to talk to you anytime today or
tomorrow about it if you believe it's
absolutely impossible to do any of this
I'd like to know about that too before I
go off and finish it
my research budget is limited just like
everybody else's but I feel in my bones
that it's something I'd like to have we
had it 20 years ago with tops 10 tops 20
systems and I'd like to sort of regain
that and perhaps even go further than we
were able to go 20 years ago with that
kind of thing
yes hi well I kind of like what you're
trying to do but I really don't like the
way you're trying to implement it it
seems to me you do this without any
modification of any of the clients or
any extensions to the axe server all you
need to do is to implement a nested
server that the client that I've already
have a nested ex server which takes a
bunch of clients and images of them into
an X window right as far as those
clients are concerned it's just the X
server all you need is an X server that
takes a bunch of clients images them
into a number of X windows on different
real servers and that you need that
central coordination point in order to
provide what I believe in this thing is
called control of the floor you know you
take the floor and and you have control
of what's going on anyway you need some
Co central coordination point to hand
the control the of the input device
effectively around and that's what this
pseudo server provides so for each
session you have a pseudo server which
is imaging on two windows on a number of
real servers and seems to me you can do
that you don't need to affect the
applications you don't need to change
the actual server at all we actually
we've kicked around three possible ways
of implementing this and the idea of a
super server or a nested server is one
of them that we plan to look at because
it's pretty heavy thing to be able to go
in and actually whack on the 11 server
or something like that and I'd like to
avoid that so the idea of a co server
that's like the nested server feels like
the right thing to do - to me - I agree
from writing some applications that use
this though it feels like there's some
issues that aren't addressed in X that
really have to get addressed by whatever
you implement however you implement it
and input management is a critical one I
think that's not there and being having
new tools to implement you
management and view update management
view control seemed to me to be
important and I don't know I don't know
whether or not it's doable without any
modification there's there's the other
side to looking at it too one is do you
have to make any modifications you get
existing ex applications to work and
that's true but are there new
opportunities you could have if you
thought about it a little bit further
and added some things so that new
applications could be written that went
beyond what was possible today and
that's sort of the second part and to me
the more interesting part of doing it I
agree with you I think it's possible for
existing X applications to continue
working I sure hope it is or we're in
trouble hi thank you I wanted to also
endorse this I think this is very
important work we're trying to look at
this - at Bell core we had sort of a
similar idea of making a box that look
like a server to the application and a
bunch of applications to all the various
servers but also have an overlay
capability to be doing drawing and
passive pointing that because any window
that multiple people can see you
probably want to have some sort of
passive conversation on top of so so
perhaps thank you but that I wanted to
tell you that I thought this was very
important work and endorsed this kind of
stuff in the community please come talk
to me afterwards I'd like to data
questions thank you very much
[Applause]